[Music]
from missions to mars
oh my god to billionaire businessmen in
orbit
one zero space exploration
is thriving but so too
are threats to satellites and other
types of spacecraft from hostile states
it's why back on earth the uk has opened
a space command
to offer them better protection
more muted but no less meaningful moment
right now we see countries like russia
and china
testing and demonstrating anti-satellite
weapons
satellites with all of the
characteristics of a weapon
deployed in space we see them rehearsing
uh maneuvers which frankly have only one
purpose which is to destroy satellites
so that's a real concern to us this new
command
at a royal air force base in high
wycombe will improve the uk's visibility
of what's going on in space
using radars and satellites
these the first service men and women to
receive their
space operator badges
visiting vips tried out new virtual
reality gear that's used in training
they say their focus is on deterring
attacks in space
by developing international rules to
govern behaviour
but britain may yet need to develop
space weapons as well to fend off
attacks
i'm not ruling out what we might do in
future but we don't want to weaponize
space we don't want
it to become a place where to use your
language you know there's conflict or
even war in space
we want to make sure that it's a common
good for all because we all derive so
much benefit from it
the uk space command is starting small
with the number of personnel involved
ranging from the tens into the hundreds
but commanders have big ambitions
potentially even creating a whole new
space force
with troops able to blast into orbit
there's no such thing as a day without
space operations
you just don't see them the united
states already has its own space force
and welcomed the uk's actions earth is
only half the battle
allies in space as important as back on
the ground
it's time for another giant leap debra
haynes sky news united states space
force is being